[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 50th episode of chess trap
series
in this episode i am going to show you a
wonderful
high profile trap in the queen's gambit
decline
from the white perspective the most
amazing part is the chess legend
tigran petrossian was the first victim
of this trap and not only him
time to time many strong players
has fallen into this
well the critical position arises after
the following
opening model d4
d5 c4 e6
knight to c3 knight to f6
and now we have the exchange variation
c catches d5 e captures d5
and bishop to g5 so the idea is very
obvious
white wants to capture this knight and
if black recapture with the queen then
we can lop it off the d5 pawn
so wisely enough the main line continue
with
bishop to e7 unpinning the knot
and white liberate his second bishop
with e3 okay
c6 consolidating the center
and before we move on the important
point i like to mention here that
many people doesn't know why this is
considered as a main line
as c6 is definitely not a forcing move
but to understand this let's say black
wants to play
an active chess so most probably he
wants to take out the light squad bishop
and bishop to f5 looks the obvious
response
but this is exactly theory is very
helpful
because after bishop captures f6 bishop
captures f6
and the move queen to b3 you can see
suddenly two of the black pawns are
hanging
and unfortunately for black he cannot
defend
both of them so now you can understand
the importance of the c6 move
let's roll it back for the few moves
and we have the c6 mainline move
on the board and accordingly
white plays queen to c2
not allowing the dark square bishop to
be developed
and in his near future he wants to play
bishop to d3
and completely shut down this knight to
e4 idea
by black
well obviously black knows this and
that's why
many strong players has continued the
move
knight to e4 attacking the g5 bishop
well as per the online database this
move
has been played in more than 180 games
where i'm afraid black has straight away
fallen into white trapping territory
what actually black was hoping is
exchange of some minor pieces for
example
bishop captures e7 queen captures e7
and now after knight captures e4 and the
move
d captures e4 you can see black
managed to exchange two minor pieces and
he has
space in the center which already give
black a great equality just within
the opening stage so that is what
black is hoping for
but unfortunately if white wants
he can get a completely winning
advantage
from here so before i move on guys
i like you to pause this video and find
out
that killer sequence which
gives wide a completely upper hand
are you ready let's get start
the first move is very obvious bishop
captures e7
now it's worth to consider king captures
e7
because after this move white clearly
get a winning advantage
with the following sequence knight
catches e4
d captures e4 and queen captures e4
not only winning the pawn but black king
is completely misplaced
so nope king captures e7 is right out of
the equation
obvious move here is queen captures e7
hoping for knight captures e4
but this is where exactly black get the
root shock
and i hope you indeed spot it right
yup knight captures d5
bam
what a move
first thing first this knight is
attacking the queen
and queen has to stay in protection of
the e4 knight
so for example if black foolishly play
here
moves like queen e6 then after knight to
c7
check he is going to lose his queen
and the second option queen to h4 is
not good either because this time around
white will get the rook in the corner
so considering all this factor here the
fourth response is
c captures d5 but after this
white successfully regained the peace
with a pawn advantage
queen capture check and you might think
okay i will block it with the queen
and in end game i can fight for the draw
well guess what the position get
more worse with the following lovely
move
bishop to b5 jack
if the king moves then queen captures b7
is a very strong reply
same goes for knight to d7 so the only
logical reply here is
knight to c6 after that
the killer sequence continue bishop
capture c6
pawn capture c6 and now wonderful
queen capture c6 which completely
misplace
all black pieces because you cannot
block with queen
as your rook on 8 hangs and after the
funny move
king to f8 and knight to e2
if you carefully look at the final
position
not only wide emerge with a two point
advantage
but blacking is completely misplaced and
with the accurate play this is
definitely
a completely winning position
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high-profile trap in the queen's gambit
declined
remember once you open and play the moon
knight to e4
give him the root shock with the
following sequence
bishop captures e7 queen captures e7
and now knight captures d5 and after
this
however black plays he get a completely
losing position
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care